These are the faces of black soldiers during the American Civil War.
They're rare photographs of some of the 200,000...
...who fought in the Union army against the southern Confederacy.
The pictures offer slices of life that many Americans may not be aware of.
Stories like that of Adele Logan Alexander's great grandfather, John Robert Bond.
He was born in England in 1846.
When he was 17 years old, hearing about the struggle for Africans' freedom...
...in the United States, the story my mother told me was that he got on a fishing boat...
...and came to Massachusetts because he wanted to help free the slaves.
Adele Alexander is a historian.
She says her great grandfather joined the Union navy and was almost killed in a battle.
It's just one of the many facts Alexander uncovered about her family.
She says her great grandfather sacrificed to help future generations.
Alexander says the Civil War not only freed the slaves,...
...it empowered African Americans to take control of their lives.
But there's a downside.
For example, at least half of African American children were being raised by a single parent,...
...according to the 2005 census data.
And black unemployment is at 15 and a half percent,...
...almost double the national average.
The Civil War itself was a part of the great legacy of slavery in this country...
...and we still live with that every day.